unfortunately we're going to begin with
the heartbreak in alabama
in the wake of that devastating storm
the tropical storm system called
claudette brought strong winds flash
flooding and tornadoes
more than a dozen people were killed
including 10 children
nine of them in a single crash many
other people were left hurt
or with no place to live jesse mitchell
is outside baptist medical center in
montgomery alabama for us where some of
the injured are being treated jesse good
morning to you just an awful awful
situation
how are people responding down there
it's certainly a sad morning here in
alabama tony as some are recovering
many are mourning the dead most of whom
likely died
in a crash that was likely caused by
hydroplaning on the wet roads
two among the dead were young fathers
with their young children
for the family of cody fox and his
daughter ariana
father's day is forever changed the
volunteer firefighter
and nine-month-old are among 10 dead
from this
multi-car crash on the highway near
greenville alabama
it's a tragedy for alabama and it's a
it's a national
tragedy when you lose this many children
the other eight
all traveling together in a van from the
tallapoosa county girls ranch
a nonprofit that provides a home for
neglected or abused children
there's no words that can describe the
loss
that we all feel right now we love these
children they're like our children
the grief is more than i can put into
words
the kids ranging from three to 17 were
heading back to the ranch
after a week at the beach the ranch
director was driving the vehicle
and is the only survivor after being
pulled out of the burning van by a
bystander
drenching rains severe winds and
suspected tornadoes in alabama and
across the florida panhandle
demolished homes and tore apart
buildings in louisiana
cars struggled as heavy rains flooded
streets and homes
it was completely flooded all the way we
couldn't get out
there was no way we could have gotten
out we saw somebody walking
down the road it was up to their waist
at least
back here in alabama the ntsb and local
authorities are working together to
investigate what happened
in that crash as for claudette the storm
is now moving to north carolina
and will continue east strengthening
back into a tropical storm
before heading out over the atlantic
anthony all right jesse thank you such a
huge loss there